hey we're 5 seconds of summer and today
we'll be reading thirst tweets and then
later you'll be listening to our new
single teeth teeth teeth Michael
Clifford gives me a boner and I don't
even have a dick that's good that's
probably the highest compliment you
could ever receive that really is oh
this is alright I said this in 2013 and
I'll say it again right now I would let
5 sauce rule in my life it's a long time
we've been ruining this girl's life for
a while no she said she'd let you
oh hey Calum hood from fire sauce cheese
I want to floss with your pubic hair is
that it that's the end that's the end
this as a bad tweet and I'm thirsty it
is bad I am fully convinced 5 sir sir
the hardest boys I'm 25 I'm a man boys
to ever set foot on this quantity boys
like boys who is boys boys Michael
Clifford could call me trash and I'd
still lick his feet as the world never
seen your fate
oh I hope no it's a good I hope no I
don't even need your feet before maybe
you should take that one back no offense
but I'll gladly let Luke Hemmings ruin
my life I'm telling you dude there's a
theme going on I'm why am I such a
destroyer I think you just come off as a
bit of a mean guy a bit of a [ __ ]
maybe oh this is sweet here's a list of
things I would let Luke Hemmings do to
me one anything - everything I like that
looks thought that with oh this is this
is sweet Jesus if I could like a shadow
his body up and down I would lick
Ashton's orange body up and down I
wouldn't like it just so you know Luke
Hemmings from five so it's gonna have
this Buzzi all to himself
your letter said my psycho is a [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay okay I get the fattest lady
boner when fat sauce curses well yeah
enjoy yourself yeah Calum would you make
me feel like a fox ate my heart then
spit it on my face
that's Paul Street okay I want a five
seven with five sauce and get some of
that five sauce winky face
that's my favorite one okay I crave a
Shannara more than I crave sleep and
Wi-Fi so that's got to count for
something right it's gotta count for
something right I'm gonna soften this
one a bit Ashton Irwin let me eat that
like a concise McGriddle with extra
maple syrup I'd tear that bit up
I'd say it's um just warm on that she
filming your needs could be the apple
pie on the side I had munch munch dad
then I launched it down with a cold
glass of my tears double lunch I like it
dude that's ambitious yeah for you
eternal wordsmith that is the definition
of the third that starts yeah Wi-Fi
sauce and we have been emotionally
scarred by BuzzFeed
[Music]